the Joe Rogan experience do you remember
when Mario Sperry got tapped out by that
badass Russian dude it was the baddest
Russian do the Russian dude was the same
guy that Frank Shamrock ko'd with a slam
trying to remember I'm all Sulu EV who
Mario Sperry I look like he opened up a
couple of gyms called Hard Knocks 365
yeah that's where he was originally to
Google of Frank shamrocks mixed martial
arts record it's Frank Shamrock
slam this dude in Kyoto and this guy was
famous for having beaten Mario Sperry
and the old school was it called battle
battle Kade
I'm the Rick stream fights extreme
fighting that's what it was extreme
fighting battle Kade that was where
Eddie's organization that was Waco
non-full my Maurice Smith so here it is
go where we at here go back little low
hold on sup sup sup sup sup
Igor's and OVF that's what was in
remember Yegor disease yes dangerous guy
well Igor had cut Mario Sperry open he
big ass gashes forehead and Mario went
up tapping the Igor zenovia was look I
think it was a Samba guy yeah I remember
that guy
tough [ __ ] yeah there was some
scary dudes that passed through the USA
a while back I remember there were two
they were from the Red Devils there was
Andre semenov in a mosque Sulu EV whoa
wait a minute wait korsunova was Jeffrey
Epstein security guard no [ __ ] way
that's right oh my God look at his face
that's him that's crazy dude that is
crazy former MMA guy gives alarmingly
cagey interview about working for
Jeffrey Epstein click on that we've got
all this [ __ ] to the farm for it
alarmingly kg interview
who is this saying this MMA - guy dos
Deadspin us
oh so scroll down
a little bit let me see what the [ __ ] it
has to say here so that's crazy that
we're talking about this guy just
randomly Wow
he said one thing you told me for
instance okay one thing you told me is
he got it heads up when the authorities
were going to come to his house the
night before he said and he says listen
what you say is between you and me okay
let's leave this alone
but anyway feel free to Google ladies
and gentlemen that's crazy I was just
bringing him up and it turns out he was
Jeffrey Epstein security guard that's
crazy
he was a real veteran I mean that guy
was on the early early days of the John
Peretti promotion he was a beast man I'm
getting those video cassettes from yes
Virgin Megastore in town
UFC two and three man I remember when
you first started fighting in the UFC I
remember those days
yeah it's crazy it seems like it was a
long time ago but not really like it
still seems like it makes sense
[Applause]